今日は
知恵の輪をします
Cast エニグマっていうね
難易度が全部マックスなんですよ
なかなか難しいと言われております
てかもう全部マックスなんすよ
まあ何故いきなり
まあ何故いきなり知恵の輪をしようかと言いますと
まあ俺のね、頭の良さを君たちに教えたいわけよ
これ難易度マックスのCastエニグマっていうね
まあパズル
いわゆる知恵の輪ってやつなんですけども
まあ俺ぐらいの
まあ、俺ぐらいの知恵があるとね
レベルマックスの知恵の輪なんて
５秒で解きますよ、５秒
ああ、このパターンね
ああ、よくあるよくある
こういう感じでございます
まあこのパターンはね
まあこれぐらいなら全然余裕ですね
３つあるんすよ
で、この３つを、まあ、
取るとクリアという事でございます
最高級レベルである事に間違いはない
テーマは
巻
するりと抜けるから力は不要
力は不要か
動画的にできなかったら
俺死ぬパターンだ
あーあんま見ない方が良いな
Core（今日）は手元を映そう（？）
ストップウォッチ置いときます
レディ
ゴー
えー？これ、わ、ちょっと待って
マジで言ってんの？
これ大分難しいべ
ちょっと待って
考えろ
ヤバい
ちょっと待って
え？
これどうなってんの？
無理でしょ
いや無理だよね
こうっしょ
あ、きたきたきた
で、ここを、もー
ここを抜ければ俺の勝ちなんですよ
そう簡単にいかせてくれないだろうから
俺はここをこうするよ
いや、こうしてこうして
あーー
んでここをこうしてこうするでしょ
あ、これいけそうだわ
あ、ここをこうして
いやこれちょ
これちょっ待ってよ
難易度マックスは伊達じゃねえーぜ
これマジでどうすればいい？
いやでもマジ解くから
ちょ見てて
臭っ
もーーーー！！
何でできない？
おいおいマジかよ
ちょ待て待て
は？
んでこれを入りたい俺本当は
いかせてくれないと
うん
それは分かったよ
そこをいかせてくれないのは分かった
としたら俺はこっちからこういきたいわけよ
だからそれすらもいかせてくれないってことっしょ？
無理じゃん！
ちょっと待って！？
は！？
おい
おま、マジふざ、なんなんだ、おい
あぁーーー！！
もー
ちょ待て待て待て待て
あぁーーー！もー！
あぁー
うぅぅ
これやっぱやばいな
これガチで多分
何人の人がこれをやってきて死んだか
これ多分死者出てるよ
は、無理でしょ
うん
それが無理なのは分かった
無理なのは分かったが俺はそこをいきたいと思ってる
だがいけないと
うーん
そうくるか
なら俺はこっちからこうするぞ？
どうだ
通ったよな
そこまではいいんだよ
だがこっからだよ
こっからお前はどう来たい？
こうか？
そっちの方向で来るか
だがここはいかせてくれないんだよな？
あーやっぱだめだよな？うん
そう、そうくるのは分かってた俺は
だから俺はこっからさらにこう仕掛けて
こっから通すぞ
こっからくるんくるんやっちゃうからな
が、それも無理なんだよな
それは分かるよ
こういきたいわけだ
でもそれはさせてくれない
となると
いやこれ答えないの？
え、解答が入ってないって書いてある
って、待って答えが入ってないと
なると
まあ答えは自分で見出すしかないよな
♬～
あっ！
おー！
取れた！
取れた！取れた！
取れた取れた！
取れた！
え！？取れた！
おいおいおい、おい、おい
おい、おい、おい、おい、おい
待って
あと２つなんすけど
え、待って待って待って
さすがにこれで
２個で取れなかったら俺ヤバいよ
ただもう２時間経ってる
ありゃ
ここからが難しいのかな？
いや無理でしょ
ラスト２個から急に難しくなった気がするんですけど
あっ
できた...
できたー！
できた！
２時間半かかりました
あー超頭痛ぇ
本当に頭痛い